We are here with the one and only Molly Sims.
(audience cheering)
What are you teaching us today, Molly teach, us.
Okay, first of all, I'm gonna talk about the importance
of Packing Cubes.
You can get them anywhere, Walmart, Amazon,
wherever you wanna go.
These will change your life because everything is packed.
So when you're like through your suitcase
to try to find something, you can just, okay,
I'm gonna put this here, I'm gonna put this here.
If you have kids, families, whatever,
it's so easy, you can roll,
you can fold underwear, swimsuits t-shirts,
Ziploc bags.
I know plastic, don't don't judge me, they work.
You can literally put outfits
just like a Packing Cube, into Ziploc bags.
So you can reuse them over and over and over again,
Over and over and over.
This is a more eco way to approach a Ziploc.
But I have my Ziplocs that have had for like five years,
I keep using them and I pack in outfits.
So as much as I'll do a plastic Ziploc,
I'll do like a hanging with exact outfit.
Like I knew what I was gonna come and wear today.
Like I thought it out, less stress.
Also toiletries, don't leave them out,
don't put them in a Packing Cube,
you put them in something that it's, this-
When they leak you won't
totally be bummed out.
This is going to spill.
And you're going to hate it.
I gonna challenge you for my next little tip.
Okay, here's what we're gonna do,
when you pack you have to learn to roll.
So I'm gonna challenge you,
'cause I know you travel and I know you pack.
I know how to roll a few things.
You know how to roll a few things.
All right, are you ready?
Okay, we're gonna put 30 seconds on the clock.
Okay, ready?
And see whoever can roll more articles of clothing
to put them into their suitcase wins.
Ready? Go.
(upbeat music)
It makes such a difference.
I know, isn't this crazy?
Oh my God.
Why, why is this so exciting?
Look how cute this shirt is.
It's so cute, by the way.
Well, I think we both won this challenge.
Yeah, I think so.
Yeah, listen, let's just hang out more.
Molly Sims, you could listen to Molly's podcast,
Lipstick on the Rim, wherever you get your podcasts.
(upbeat music)